ندره المياه مشكله عالميه مع ذلك تتبخر
مياه المحيطات المجاوره للمناطق شبه
الاستوائيه مثل غرب الولايات المتحده على
سبيل المثال باستمرار بسبب وجود ما يكفي
من الاشعاع الشمسي وقله التغطيه السحابيه
على مدار العام هذه هي الفكره التي تحاول
دراسه جديده من جامعه اوربانا شامبين
اقتراح الاستثمار فيها فهم يرون ان ارتفاع
درجه حراره المحيطات بسبب التغيرات
المناخيه هو نفسه الحل لمشكله ندره المياه
العذبه فهناك امدادات غير محدوده من
المياه العذبه الموجوده في شكل بخار الماء
فوق محيطات الارض لكنها لا تزال غير
مستغله ويقترح العلماء جمع بخار مياه
المحيطات كحل للامدادات المحدوده من
المياه العذبه في مواقع تليفه حول العالم
وفق الدراسه فانه بامكان مساحه تجميع مياه
مسطحه لا يتجاوز ارتفاعها 100 متر وطولها
220 امتار ان توفر المياه الصالحه للشرب
لاكثر من 500,000 شخص بدلا من الارتفاع في
الغلاف الجوي سيتم التقاط الهواء المشبع
بالمياه بواسطه اجهزه الاستخراج الموجوده
قبله الساحل ثم تكثيفه ونقله بواسطه
الانابيب هي ثم تخزينه قبل اعاده توزيعه
الدراسه التي قادها استاذ الهندسه المدنيه
والبيئيه برافين كومار قيمت مواقع تعاني
الاجهاد المائي في جميع انحاء العالم
لدراسه جدوى وجود بنيه افتراضيه قادره على
التقاط بخار الماء من فوق المحيط وتكثيفه
في المياه العذبه في تظهر التوقعات
المناخيه ان نتدفق بخار المحيط سيزداد
بمرور الوقت مما يوفر المزيد من امدادات
المياه العذبه الفرق وانهم سوف يستطيعون
توجيها الى اين يذهب الماء المتبخر من
المحيط هل يمكن لهذه الدراسه ان تفتح
الباب امام استثمارات جديده في البنيه
التحتيه تساعد في معالجه ندره العالميه
المتزايده للمياه العذبه بشكل فعال